you see people play basketball
some [__] are great basketball
players and they're good like any other
any other court you put them on there
are [__] amazing
but then you put them on a court with
lebron and [__] steph curry and k.d
and they look like children you give
what i'm saying they're not built for
that
they bought it really physically not
built for that bro
he's like you just not made for this
[__] you're the best point guard in the
league but you can never be a [__]
small forward you'll never be a sinner
but then it's some [__] who you
could put them on the court and you
don't even have to tell them what to do
some there's some people just naturally
gifted bo jackson's
deion sanders the [__] you know what
i'm saying the talent just [__]
proceed the odell beckham's they can do
any [__] thing bruh
and they just ain't good at it if
they're not good at it they're at least
good enough at it to captivate you and
make you watch them not be good at it
so you got to have self belief too man
that's got to play into it that
confidence seems the longer i've been
doing comedy you know i've been doing it
over eight years now and it seems like
confidence can
really drive the audience response
yeah man if you can make people like you
it doesn't matter what you say because
they like you
they want you that when people like you
they treat you different
because you give them something you give
them a feeling
it's happiness if you can make people
happy [__] what you do [__] the jokes
that you told they'll come see you a
hundred times cause you make them happy
it's an atmosphere you acknowledge them
you talk to people different
that's the part about that's the part
when you can find out what makes people
like you that's what'll make you a star
that's why kevin hart is winning so hard
right now he found out how to make
people like him
he's a likable you want to see him win
you celebrate his victories with him
because he make you feel like you're a
part of
so find out what people like about you
right it might not necessarily be the
jokes
it might be your stupid aunt's pants or
your little
boyish grin or your voice they just
might like you because you're a tall
[__] or they might like you
because you're a pretty fat [__]
you're just a fly person you smell good
you carry yourself different you got a
different swag your delivery
you gotta accent from where you from it
all go back to you though
like what type you got to find like this
is my best advice find a highlighter and
use it on yourself
like if you're a woman with some big ass
titties let people know you know you got
them [__] so you got big brown eyes or
whatever the [__]
all of these are your weapons if you can
sing if you can do an impression you can
sound just like a [__] these are
all
talents you bring to the stage because
they only get that [__] from you
you